sammy
what's going on sammy
sammy wool 19. hello
sashirmu
says much love jerry booger
booger cat lunch thank you for the tier
one sub okay
it's go time make a move
played this guy quite a bit
let's not be too pre-move happy
support the night
no quick d4 there huh
i could take my bishop's defended
i i don't have a good position
i should have challenged that night much
sooner
that square covered where you going
knight on b5 i back up to b2
knight's under control or is he
that's a really good square my knight is
stupid
their knight is very good oh they have
have enough on that i just dropped a
pawn
have that square covered
i don't like my position
i have a time edge
mm-hmm
on f5
trying to get it there king
i think i am getting in the seventh rank
hey can maybe be a little scared no
it's not there
i have a pawn at least
oh here this is a good finish because i
get the passer
not going to allow that though
just let all the pawns fall right
okay
that night on c4 was dangerous
light square he's licking his chops
where was my light square bishop nowhere
to be found is
gonzo traded on e2
do not create light square holes
when you don't have a light square
bishop
you might just get hurt
don't take an e5 got taken the bishop
i could take with the knight my queen's
defending take with the knight free the
bishop
open file stop knight c4
what was that move about
i could work around a knight on this
square just back off let's get some play
on the queen side
give up a pawn for no good reason why
not here
let's get him back there gonna take with
the knight
this is sensitive
let's control the knight
get out of there
i have this square
trying to trade oh i could have played
there
okay let's try now a good time edge
no entry points my bishops are really
good
um my knight on c4 yes didn't i learn
from that last game a night on c4 is
pretty good
am i just helping
what did i really accomplish there huh
somebody tell me
[Laughter]
this is floundering
big time edge that's about it
okay he's trying to go fast
there we go two two w's in there
donnie rules donnie rolls
let's try d or yeah e4 against donny
rules
get some space
we got c3 in there stop knight before in
case there's the capture
no knight on f5
close it down close it down king side
play
get rid of the dark square bishops he's
a bad guy
four coronies stop a fork
okay well my knight is covering that
actually
i'm gonna go pawn hunting swipe the
knight
be greedy take that pawn come back
get out of pins nothing happening on the
queen side
really
uh
i don't mind if it's completely closed
down okay how do i make progress
that's helpful actually
i think
um here here
here here here just want everything
nice and cozy
i could pile up on this point
the queen should be the one take with
the pawn
get my king in now
and i can make a play over here
or here we'll make progress
i will find you
little liam neeson watch out
for four caronies there it is
i will find you
what a great movie i've watched that
movie so many times
taken
take a one taking two it can't beat
taken one though
the first one first one is the best one
all right maybe i should flick in the uh
scandinavian
just for fun instead of caro
all right clamp town on the queen side
it was a pawn
that was just some kind of scare tactic
you know
tactics
that's such a good show scare tactics
all right i'm anticipating there's going
to be a problem here so
what's my queen doing over here way over
here in left field
let's defend my apon and come over here
and defend
there could still be some trickeronies
queen takes f5
at some point fork nearby
they're in the dark where'd you go
i don't know if this break is even
helping me
i want my knight here how do i pull that
up
oh how about a night here oh that's
looking juicy
something something good is bound to
happen
we get a lot of stuff now just the
thought of a night on that square was
dangerous
one of my favorite scare tactics
the show scare tactics the pranks
is the one with the plumber
has anyone seen that one
look up scare tactics plumber
oh this kid gets so scared
okay here i go
oh when i'm not thinking i'm just
playing this variation
on autopilot
could have captured on h6 i don't want
to recapture
towards the center let's not break any
rules i see a square
ready to jump in when
right now shut it down
go for a minority break give up a pawn i
got this guy
all right
oh my queen doesn't have to capture on
this square
she has she has that
that's a little concerning though it's a
little concerning
broke up and over i want one rook off
the pressure's
maybe a little too much okay
yeah how about i got my base points
covered though
queen's guarding everything
we just trade take with check
check grab that pawn quick little sniper
trading machine
the wheels are in motion they have a
check
we got checks here though one king and
pawn ending
i almost played to f2 oh man
really i
almost played there
wrong square man wrong square
okay back in the ring back to tournament
133 are in here
15 minutes to go where did the time go
oh i played him oh he just won his game
we're gonna get this this pairing
he had me on the ropes that night on c4
having flashbacks to the knight on c4
all right king's indian defense
okay get this guy out
keep the pin all right they're giving me
some squares to work with
right there i could take there right
why not
maybe another pawn off the knight moves
c5
what's the deal here what's this story
take with check save the bishop i just
want a piece
full piece i'm up a night
that ends c3
is good that's just trade
ah they could have captured there queen
was had pressure
bishop here let's back off
my knight wants to be where light on f5
push him knight onto d5
prove take here forks
still there queen on d5 mates
two threat got it
i resigned okay got 20
some fire
mouse is going smooth
usually it's a little slower when i
stream
but it's it's going good
got got some speed
let's go here i'm trying to get e4 in
without giving up
knight b5 jump change my mind i'm gonna
focus on b5
out of any pins maintain this guy here
he's a tough guy okay now
i was thinking about even going back
home i need to control the night night
there would have been a move too
my rook is what was unprotected
duck the knight exchange let's get a
flight square in there
okay there's a lot of interesting
ideas now knight on d4 b4 dark squares
are
compromised um
thinking about taking with the not about
taking with the pawn
all right let's go here
okay they have a good night and i want
to poke around at these dark squares
okay um
let's see let's hold my ground here
let's not get too crazy
in betweener if h3 um
back off got to go faster
check her knight is pinned
they're in a giant pickle
get their queen if they take now
enter
okay no time
down on the clock all right 24
20 16s
11 to go
all right dennis try b3
ah i'll take with the pawn i guess
am i not winning a pawn
got some night night move here take with
the bishop
i could take take the knight and be on
the queen
all right i want my queen to patrol the
dark squares
oh fancy
okay queen is excellent on c3 the the
knight is pinned
unpinned but still probably pinned
really oh i guess he is unpinned
wow all right queen there knight g5
feels like i should have some trick up
my sleeve
soon good coordination
and a lot of stuff pointing over here
knight f6 necessary
this move coupled with
bishop here seems nice
king king here i have that
get the queen night is pinned
and is pinned still
somewhat pinned this time
just looking to trade
trade away of material
they're in a pickle
cool mate coming up two diagonals okay
good game 28 with fire nine nine
remaining
165 in here
um
mike
pressure here i like seeing c4 i'm more
concerned about a knight going into c4
to put pressure here
king in on one square remove pieces that
could control that
mount this i'm getting a pawn
trade dark square bishops i could have
captured the knight
oh that guy was up for grabs
uh they're still in a pickle okay
might as well stir up some trouble i
could have captured there too i'm
missing
missing some free stuff well let's just
go here i could a lot of different ways
to do it
up a piece the rook just want the queens
off
got a fork
all right they resigned 32
26 23 this guy is
still around a little berserk
18 berserk
he's in a uh this guy's in a game yeah
okay let's try f4
space space invader pawn
on an e5 i want to maintain a knight on
f3
to be careful my dark squares yeah
knight there
i should have captured that night first
um i was just thinking that i have like
another knight to develop
nope this is all i have i need to make a
break
this is the only one c4
where's your king going by the way this
rook better not move i will grab this
the queen and the
oh nice maneuver forgot about that one
feel that black is better now yeah
yes this is very good to have black i
would love to play this position as
black here
b4 break
the rook is a little clumsy
but structure wise i like i like
black i am getting some play here some
some some pressure
yeah i'm gonna grab that a pawn
how do i want to do this
i just get that pawn straight up
bishop's in the way of getting my a apon
now it's collapsing this guy's
kind of silly this is where it's it went
a little wrong that
that rook was misplaced
get the bishop soon they're down on time
all right five and change
all righty nearly 200 in here
renegade all right e4 against renegade
the french turned king's indian attack
sort of
okay i have a square oh they they tried
to castle they can't castle huh
uh what's wrong with that pun why am i
so afraid of grabbing a pawn
it's free take away from the center
let that pond see the world
should be something good happening for
me on the dark squares get mated in two
if they try to kick
centralize they can take that pawn
i don't take free pawns but i give free
pawns what's wrong with queen g6
your pot is pinned i can't you know they
can't do anything at this guy
defending here okay the dark squares
come on something's got to give here
break it down break it down
something juicy is happening take with
the knight
he's a beast
um
fancy that one was fancy
i didn't get the most out of that down
on time
you're gotta be asking for trouble now
there's no way
discovered tricks
okay can i just take free pieces finally
whoa
my time my time
okay get the rooks off or i get a piece
be much easier for me to play now
pre-move out there we go
i got this as long as my mouse is going
smooth
i feel confident
all right got 42 and change remaining
man
i should have captured on e5 i think my
opponent should capture it on e4
guys right on my tail
gotta keep winning gotta get this one oh
it's my move yeah
i blinked
i blinked
um here's okay
maintain a knight on f6
here here i guess
take here gotta go with an in-betweener
first
it's a little scary that my rooks are
both on light squares
why did i just shut that bishop out
trade rooks and play c4 next time would
you
okay he's under control
i don't like that let's go here
here push through
get a flight square kn g7 is what i want
there was a better way pretty sure there
was a better way stop h5
okay now we could win this guy
trade cover my base points
now we get that this guy
rook c1 i have this back off
push through with this guy can't be
stopped
the queen's off
okay oh that's the last game
is this guy gonna win
he just won he's not getting a parent oh
he
did just win it just got up there 47 44.
was i just reading that wrong all along
i was i think i was in first and just up
by three
nope wow you had a lot of games in there
too
271 performance 19 berserk
well done how many games did i have in
there
12 games 16 games
nice okay final standings 190
194 in there 47 44
28. nice there's your top ten
let's check out let's check out
everybody who
competed why not slipping jimmy
is in there
accelerated dragon chess math
chess math nerd sister
metal sailor
raider player just
calling out random names
and
that's everyone alright
good games oh
you